Speaker 1: Let's go next to. Oh, boy.
I have no idea how to say this name. I
believe it's a Scottish name.
Speaker 3: Yeah, it would be.
Speaker 1: I'm going to just take a wild guess
at how it's pronounced, even though they're so.
Go for it. Is it pronounced Rory?
Speaker 3:
You are very close. Is our brewery.
Speaker 1: Brewery? Okay. Well, listen,
Rory from Scotland, welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Hi, there.
Speaker 1: What's on your mind?
Speaker 3: I was just.
I was just thinking, just because, you know, I
have sort of, like an outside view of the U.S.,
obviously, being from across the pond. I was just
wondering what your opinion was on the sort of
like global right wing populist movement, whether
you think it was as strong as it was back in 2000,
during the 20 tens when, you know, Brexit
happened and Trump got elected and all that?
Or do you think now it's in more of a retreat and
you see some of these extreme policies come from
the Republicans and the conservatives over here as
their last kind of like flailing of a sort of like
ideology that's kind of feeling at the moment.
Speaker 1: I don't have anything empirical to tell
you globally about whether the right wing populist
movement is in retreat or not. My feeling. Okay.
So I'm just going by feeling and I know facts
don't care about feelings, but I have no facts,
so I'm going to give you my feelings. Right. My
feeling is that because of the losses that the
MAGA right wing populist movement has suffered now
multiple elections in a row in the United States,
and the degree to which anti woke doesn't seem
to be winning and they're suffering legal defeats
and moral defeats. My feeling is that it is
at least starting a retreat at this time.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 1: And I don't know where one gets
us in terms of like the 2024 election necessarily.
Speaker 3: Yeah, for sure. Like I kind of for in
the UK, it's kind of the same because you have
the conservatives who have like been trounced at
local elections and they're polling really badly
nationally, but they're still like pushing the
same sort of like culture war policies that have
just kind of been imported from America. So like
the whole trans rights debates has flared
up, especially where I'm from in Scotland.
So I, I think just looking over here, I
think in some places like the US and the
UK is faltering quite a lot just because
of not necessarily the ideology in itself,
but the incompetent people behind it.
Speaker 1: It's both. Right. I mean,
you can you can take bad ideas and popularize them
with competent demagogues. You can take good ideas
and see them lose miserably because the messengers
aren't good. You could both can have. Yeah,
exactly. Yeah.
Speaker 3:
All right. That's all I would
ask. Yeah. Thank you very much.
Speaker 1: Appreciate it. Great to hear from
you. Excellent. Always welcoming our Scottish
callers. Let's go to Jean from Long Island. Jean,
welcome to the David Pakman Show. What is on your
mind today? Hello. Hi. You're on the air.
Speaker 2: Awesome. My dad has raised me as
a progressive. And the most thing the thing I've
cared most about while growing up is reproductive
rights. And so we've been blaming the GOP and
Trump taking credit for overturning Roe. But
looking back, I'm thinking the Democrats
should have made sure this right remained
in place. They knew the GOP was planning and
plotting for all these years. And my other I
wanted to get your thoughts on that and also
how how I can help in this fight to get it to
get those reproductive rights back. I've donated
to Planned Parenthood. But, you know, if there
if you had any inside insight on that as well.
Speaker 1: So the first criticism is a fair one,
which is couldn't Democrats, when they did
control the House and Senate and presidency,
have codified Roe v Wade such that it would no
longer be up to the Supreme Court to do away with
it? Is that more or less the critique, Jean?
Speaker 2: Yes, absolutely.
Speaker 1: I think it's completely fair.
My question is, if Obama couldn't even
get background checks done with the House
and Senate after the Sandy Hook shooting,
could they really have codified Roe v
Wade? I don't know the answer. I don't
know the answer. But I think as a criticism, it's
completely fair. Yeah. So there's a question and.
Speaker 2: It's something that actually upsets me
a lot because this is something I've cared about
for a long time. So, you know, looking into the
future, hopefully at some point we can get that
back and I just don't know how that would be.
Speaker 1: Now, in terms of your other question,
what is the best use of your time, money,
resources, whatever, in order to essentially
what you're saying is keep abortion legal and
maintain access to it for people who want to
access it. With the movement done away with with
Roe v Wade being done away with right now, this is
a state issue. So in the states that have passed
restrictive laws, you could argue it makes sense
to focus there. So I don't know exactly whether
it should be focus on getting candidates at the
state level in these states that have essentially
banned abortion to get elected. So maybe they
can overturn it. Or is it donating to Planned
Parenthood of Florida or Texas or whatever? I
don't pretend to know exactly. I probably it's
an all of the above approach. But I think that
for as long as it remains a state issue, which it
is right now, the focus for activists should be on
the states in which it is most in peril.
Speaker 2:
Awesome. Thank you. I really appreciate it.
Speaker 1: All right. Jean from Long Island,
great to hear from you. Very strong questions
today, I must say. Let's go next to Richard
from Slidell. Or is it pronounced Slidell?
Probably Slidell, right? It must be. Richard,
please. On mute. Unmute yourself, sir. Oh, boy.
Richard, you have self muted and if you unmute,
I would be able to hear you. All right.
And Richard refusing to take off that mute.